[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is what you get when
you open up the UI editors is
kind of like the base screen.
And so we have three
columns going left to right.
And so the Elements panel has
all of the various different UI
components that you
can put in your app
that you can control
with the UI editor.
So we have Action Button,
Numeric Inputs, Plot Outputs,
Cards, and Plots and stuff
like that, everything
that you would need to
make a basic app, more
of which are coming soon.
So then moving over to the
right, we have the app view.
And this isn't like an
exact view of your app.
It's more of an
abstract representation
of the app with the
intent of basically
being a visual
representation of the code.
And the reason why is that a
lot of times, your actual app
may have stuff like
dynamic UI in it.
And so we can't know what
that would look like.
So this is basically
a way of, we're
going to put things
in the right places,
and we're going to give you
the pertinent information.
But if you think of it kind
of as a wireframe of your app.
And then to the right of that,
we have the Properties panel.
And so if we select a given
UI component in the app editor
view, on the right hand side,
you get to see the properties.
And so you see where
that given component
is in the tree of your UI.
So you have the Grid Page.
Within that, you
have the Grid Card.
And within that,
you have the Slider.
And then you have
the various settings
like Input ID, Label, the
values that you can change.
And all of these,
you change them here.
And then it will
update the app for you.
You can delete that element
down with this button.
And then beneath that, there's
a thing called the App Preview.
And so this goes
back to the fact
that this isn't a perfect
representation of your app.
You see this is not a real plot.
This just kind of
an abstract plot.
But down here, whenever
you run the UI editor,
you get a preview of the app.
And so this is what the app
looks like actually running.
And as you change
stuff within your app,
it will update down there.
So if we change the app title
content to be "Shiny UI Editor"
and we go back here, we
see that it changed here.
And so you never have to
turn off the UI editor
and restart your app to
see what it looks like.
We'll do that
automatically for you.
We'll also give you the
logs that your app puts out.
You can refresh the page
in case there's something
that changed that
needs a page refresh.
So, yeah, that's the
very basic set of tools.
And then there's
this panel up here.
It has a little bit of control.
So, say, we do something
like, take this, move it down
here, and then move our slider
up to a new card over here.
We say "newslider."
And then we say, wait a minute.
I don't actually like that.
We can use the Back button
up here to undo that change,
go back all the way
to where we were.
Maybe we did like it.
We can redo.
But let's go back to that.
So, basically, these
Undo and Redo buttons
are there to save
you if you ever
get yourself into a situation
that you don't want to be in.
You can always just
back up until your app
is working and looking the
way that you want it to.
So we talked about
the element deletions.
Let's say we want to delete
this plot called bluePlot.
We you can just click
the Delete Element.
You can see down
there, it's gone.
But once, again,
let's put it back.
Then we can do things like
resize the given component.
So, say, right now, we
have the slider on the left
and the plots on the right.
And then the plot on
the top is the same size
as the plot on the bottom.
Maybe we want to make
the plot on the top
be maybe a little bit
more of the given size.
So we can just drag this
little sizing down here.
And you see the size of
this pop up next to stuff.
And it uses this thing
called an fr, which
we'll talk about a little bit.
But that's the CSS unit.
So, basically, it's
a ratio of the sizes.
So we're going to say for every
0.5 units of the bottom plot,
the top plot is 1.5.
So it's going to be
three times the size.
We can stop there
and go back and see.
Yep, it made that change.
And so, basically, we can
use this to fiddle around
with the sizes.
Say, we're dragging this, and
we see it's 200 or 305 pixels.
And, say, we really wanted
it to actually be 300.
We couldn't get our
drag to be there.
We can mouse over that and
just go over here and type 300
and update it that way as well.
I showed it a little bit before.
But you can resize these
panels within this grid
by using these little handles.
And then you can drag them
down so-- with our settings
all the way down there.
If you wanted to, maybe we use
that to make this plot bigger.
And, yeah, you can
configure everything
to your heart's
desire, just using
underneath the hood a package
called Grid Layout, which
we are releasing in conjunction
with Shiny UI editor,
which allows you to make your
apps laid out very explicitly
with grids.
So when you actually look--
I guess we can talk
about that later.
But we just defined where
we want things to be,
how big the given elements,
the tracks of the grid
are, the rows and
columns of the grid.
And then we can just put an
element over whatever span
of contiguous rows and
columns that we want.
And we know that it's going
to be placed right there.
We don't have to work with
arbitrary restrictions
such as, we can
only have columns,
or we can only have rows.
You can have both.
Basically, if you
can imagine it,
you can put it into
the grid layout.
We can just add a bunch
of columns if we want.
And we do that by going over to
these individual column views.
And then you see there's a
little plus button over here.
And you mouse over.
It says, add a column.
So we can do that.
And then we get as
many as we want.
And so right now, we
have this name all
scrunched up over there.
But we could make it
three of the column's--
or whatever size we want to.
We can resize-- let's see.
Let's add a bunch
of rows as well.
I have to go up here.
And we're getting
a little bit crazy.
But we can make that there.
And then we can take our
second plot, make it that.
We have this kind of
crazy grid structure.
And what we could do is, say,
let's put a text input here.
So we can drag a
[? textbook ?] input.
We're going to call it namefield
or something like that.
Put it that there.
You can drag this bigger.
We could just keep
going and building
all sorts of arbitrary
sizings, title up here.
Maybe we want to put our slider
all the way up here, probably
drag this down a
little bit, so there's
a little bit more space for it.
Basically, the world is
your oyster, so to speak,
with what you put in this stuff.
So, yeah, we can
build any design
that you might possibly
want as long as it
can be expressed as a grid.
You can put it on here.
In Excel, if you want to
add a column between things,
you just kind of mouse
up in this little area,
right click here.
You don't right click.
You just hover.
And it pops up this
little interface.
You can also delete rows.
And so it will
intelligently say,
hey, you can delete this track
because everything that's
within it won't disappear.
So we can delete that.
But, say, we tried
to delete this tract.
It won't let us.
And that's because
if we delete it,
this whole element wouldn't
have nowhere to go.
And so you can simplify your--
maybe you get your layout
working the way you want to.
You can then start taking out
the various tracks to simplify.
Or you can leave them in.
It doesn't really matter.
You'll see that the code
generated for grid layout,
it's easier to read if
you have a simpler layout.
But if you don't, it
doesn't bother you,
you can have as many columns
and rows as you possibly want.
And you can make things look
exactly how you want them to.
Dynamic UI Output is
very literally just
like outputUI, renderUI.
Grid Text Card is
when you just want
to have place some
text in the grid.
And so you see here, this title
here is just a grid text card.
And so this is just a
component that you just
want to put text somewhere.
You put it in this.
And so it's usually used for
a title of your app, maybe
a footer.
It's a pretty simple function.
Grid Plot Card is
somewhat-- so see here,
this is a grid plot card.
And that can be put
directly onto the grid page.
And it's basically just like
a shortcut for having a card.
So this is a grid card.
If you were to have a grid
card and then put a plot in it,
it's essentially the same thing.
But a lot of times,
you just want
to put a plot in a given place.
A grid plot card does that.
And it takes away some of
the annoying details of--
you have to-- if you've ever
put a plot in a Shiny app, which
I would assume a
lot of people have,
you know that it starts
at 400 pixels high.
And so almost
always, you're going
to want to change that
to some other value.
And grid plot card
is smart about that
and knows that the grid
is going to give you
sizing of your plot for you.
It will set those
height and width
to automatically fill the
card space that you have.
And so that's nice, just allows
you to skip some of the syntax.
And instead of having to have a
card and then put a plot output
in there, then make sure
that the plot output is
the right sizing, you can just
drag grid plot card on there.
And so you could say, right,
how we have distPlot down here.
So if we delete distPlot
and we put a plain card here
and we call it distPlot--
and then we take a
plot output right here
and drag it in there.
So this plot output needs to
have distPlot set, distPlot.
And you see that the
height is 400 pixels.
We want to set this to 100%.
And then that's effectively
the exact same thing
that we get just for
free with grid plot card.
Another nice thing is that you
notice that all of these cards
have to have these names when
we drag something new into here.
It says you need to name this.
And that's because
grid layout needs
to have some string to identify
the given areas that you've
defined in the grid.
And a lot of times, if you're
going to put a plot there,
you probably are
making that plot area
the exact same
string as the plot
ID that you're using
to hook up your plot.
And so you can get that really
easily with grid plot card.
You put it down there.
And we just call this distPlot.
Say Done.
It automatically hooks it up
to that distplot argument.
You don't have to do that.
You see in the settings, name
of grid area is distPlot.
And then it
automatically does that.
But we could put a
different output idea
if we wanted to,
call it distPlot2.
It's going to break because
distPlot2 doesn't exist.
But the idea is that we give
as nice a default as you
could want for your plot.
And then if you
need more control,
you would just put a
plot in a grid card.
So you'll notice when we
put an element-- so, say,
we are going to drag--
the child of the
grid layout needs
to be a grid card of some kind.
We can directly put the
grid plot card there
because that's a grid card.
So it's a direct child.
But if we take something
like a numeric input,
like we had before,
and we drag it here,
it says you can
put it on the grid.
When we put it on
the grid, that's
going to ask us the
name of this grid area.
We could say [INAUDIBLE].
But then if you
actually look at this,
you'll see that it
wrapped it in a grid card.
And so this is a full card.
And you can put more stuff
in here if you wanted.
It depends.
I think that's up to
you, the app builder.
If you want to start
with placing your cards,
you could basically empty your
whole app, down to just a grid,
just super simple.
You could say, OK, I
want a bunch of columns,
and I want them all
to be the same size.
we'll make this 1 fr.
So everything is going to be--
you need evenly sized,
although this is 1.5.
So we'll change it to 1.
So now we just have a grid.
And then you could
just take your cards
and put them on there.
Call this plotA.
Position it around.
And you can just
continue to do that.
PlotB.
Title headers like that.
If you wanted to, you could
continue to do that and then
place your stuff on there.
And, honestly, if
you wanted to, you
could just use the UI editor
to build this, get your layout,
and then go into
the code, and add
your stuff within those
little built-out skeleton.
So we're agnostic about
which way you do it.
Sometimes you might want the
control of putting the grid
card directly.
But know that any time you
put an item that is not
a grid-aware item, so it's
not a grid card on it,
it's going to just wrap
it in a grid card for you.
So you can save a step
if you want but maybe you
want to put titles here.
So let's say, like,
plot A. And then
you'll get a title
for your card first.
And so maybe you want
to set it up that way
instead of going back
and retroactively
assigning the settings
for your given card.
[MUSIC PLAYING]